ma mère une fois un peu plus tôt à l'âge
de 13 ans et demi m'a trouvé mettant une
robe de nuit et alors j'ai reçu une
fameuse correction elle m'a dit je veux
pas péd dans la maison qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça on s'habille pas en femme
tu es un homme tu dois rester un homme
toujours ce mot homme qui me qui me
cassait les oreilles à longueur de
journée fa
moi l' fait l'autre
[Musique]
baña
dem dans les
[Musique]
fill de quel pays vous
venezind dit l'autre jour si mon père
savait il me tu c'est vrai
[Musique]
V je pas moi je pense ça dans ma tête
je le pense
[Musique]
vraiment
Belinda quel âge vous avez 18 ans je
rentre dans les 19 ans là il y a
longtemps que vous vous prostiuez en
France ça fait ça va faire 4 ans 5
an gagnez beaucoup d'argent
oui beaucoup d'argent qu'est-ce que vous
en faites de cet
argent l'argent je m'am mis
jamais vous dépensez comment en achetant
des freins aller en boî aller dans des
grand aller dans des restaurants c'est
important l'argent non pour moi non
c'est pas important parce que ça Dua à
quel temps presque fini qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire
après je sais
pas je en vivant c'est
viens là j'ai choisi cette vie et il
faut que je la continue fa comme je veux
comme toi tu es là pour gagner ta vie
aussi et tout le monde sont là pour
gagner leur
[Musique]
vie
j'ai quitté la Belgique parce que
j'avais envie de changer de pays de
changer d'air parce que ça n'allait pas
du tout en Belgique et j'avais envie de
de de voir un autre horizon un autre
monde et la France me plaît beaucoup
j'avais pas du travail et puis j'ai un
copain qui m'a dit tu vas voir à Paris
tu vas trouver beaucoup de travail et tu
tu vas être heureuse et tu vas enfin
pouvoir vivre aussi ton ton travestisme
c'est plus facile à Paris qu'en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Belgique je suis arrivé en France sans
rien j'avais pas d'argent presque pas
d'habit même masculin d'ailleurs j'avais
presque rien et je m'étais fait voler et
agresser j'avais le stress et je savais
pas quoi faire
quoi je vis chez un copain que j'ai
trouvé un nouvel am qui m'a accueilli et
m'éberge pour le
moment comment ça a commencé pour toi ce
goût du travestisme mais ça a commencé
étant tout petit j'avais déjà 7 ans
quand je je je m'habille en FEM et
j'imit j'imitais les speakrin de la
télévision française et autres et puis à
l'âge de 14 ans je je faisais la même
chose et ma mère une fois un peu plus
tôt à l'âge de 13 ans et demi m'a trouvé
mettant une robe de nuit et alors j'ai
reçu une fameuse correction elle m'a dit
je veux pas péd dans la maison qu'est-ce
que c'est ça on s'habille pas en femme
tu es un homme tu dois rester un homme
toujours ce mot homme qui me qui me
cassait les oreilles à longueur de
journée il fallait absolument je reste
homme et pourquoi tu avais mis sa robe
de nuit parce que je voulais être femme
parce que je voulais je me sentais bien
dès que je mettais un vêtement féminin
je me sentais très bien mes parents
n'ont jamais rien compris et je crois
qu'ils ne comprendront jamais jamais
[Musique]
rien
bonjour madame j'ai vu la une robe rouge
qui me plaît vous l'avez en d'autres ton
rouge la voici c'est pour vous oui c'est
pour moi ah d'accord bien elle existe
aussi en gris gris et rouge je pense pas
qu'il problème de taille c'est des
taille unique vu que vous êtes mince je
pense pas qu'il y a de problème sinon
vous avez d'autres modèles comme ceci
aussi vous pouvez la passer vous AZ
merci
voilà si j'avais des parents qui
j'aurais pu leur expliquer j'aurais dit
ben voilà qu'est-ce que je dois faire
euh donnez-moi des conseils est-ce que
je suis normal est-ce que c'est normal
ou est-ce que c'est pas normal tout
parents je crois aurait répondu tu
penses que tu es quelqu'un de normal oui
très
normal et à l'école comment ça s'est
passé bien à l'école la directrice m'a
surpris donc habillé en femme avec une
femme habillé en homme on s'était
travesti et alors elle a elle a elle m'a
renvoyé et a écrit une lettre votre fils
a des manières de malade mental dans
dans les couloirs de mon école et essaie
d'avoir des idées plus hautes que moi et
alors moi j'ai eu envie d'aller voir
après un psychiatre parce que je me dis
bah si elle le dit que je suis pas
normal je suis peut-être pas normal
c'est toi tout seul qui a eu cette idée
oui j'ai eu cette idée et alors ensuite
j'ai demandé à mon père de faire une
photocopie de la lettre que j'ai remis
au psychologue et il m'a dit une phrase
qui m'a fait vachement plaisir il m'a
dit tu es encore plus normal que la que
la que la
directrice il m'a dit bon c'est c'est
c'est une attitude tout à fait normale
d'aimer s'habiller en femme c'est c'est
bon c'est c'est un goût quoi c'est
chacun ses goûts alors tu dérange pas tu
as été fich sur la porte de l'école fich
la porte de chez toi ou de chez moi
aussi mon père a dit moi je veux pas de
ça chez moi et je suis
parti qu'est-ce que tu voudrais dire aux
gens bah je voudrais dire acceptez-nous
comme on est quoi et qu'on qu'on puisse
vivre heureux quoi et si on envie d'être
hab en femme et ben pouvoir avoir un
métier une formation et pourquoi
[Musique]
pas là
là vousz vous appelle travelot alors là
j'ai horreur de ça j'ai horreur de ça
c'est une insulte c'est comme quand on
dit à une prostituée quand on dit une
[__] ça m'fusque aussi hein parce que
heureusement même des prostituées qui
qui sont là parce que avec tous les vis
qui existent sera un petit peu dur hein
heureusement que les prostituées sont là
pour souvir tout ça et dans le groupe on
vous traite comme une femme ah oui dans
le groupe oui vous n'avez jamais peur
dans le
métro ça dépend ça
dépend ça dépend quand on vous attaque
qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous avez une petite fille Val je
suis pas encore grand-mère attention une
fille oui elle a quel âge 6 ans vous
avez été marié enfin marié comme ça à
l'cole quoi sans passer par l'église ni
ni ni la mairie quoi et cette fille vous
la voyez souvent moi j'y vais tous les
15 jours et vous y allit comment tel que
je suis là en fin de compte et comment
réagit la petite et ben elle rigole au
contraire ça lui plaît en fin de compte
elle m'appelle Valérie telle que je
m'appelle et puis fait des petites
parties c'est chouette on joue à la
balle je joue avec elle on cours je me
détends elle vous pose pas de question
non aucune aucune
question j pique ses poupées et votre ex
femme elle est décédé Valérie il y a
longtemps que vous vous travestissez je
me travestis depuis l'âge de 0 ans quoi
enfin enfin je pense un petit pe un
petit peu plus tard quand même et au
départ c'était quoi mais au départ je
commençais à piquer
les jupes de ma cousine et tout et
puis et puis voilà quoi puis ça a
continué ça ça continu ça continue et
vos parents réagissaient comment à
l'époque oh s'en fiche en fin de compte
c'est parce que il habitent la Russie en
fin de compte et puis sont ils sont cool
là-bas en fin de compte c'est est-ce que
vous êtes travesti aussi là-bas ah oui
oui oui à chaque fois que j'y vais sans
problème et on vous regarde comment ah
ben là on ne regarde pas c'est c'est
tout naturel làb en fin de compte ici
c'est tout un chichi si d'ailleurs je
passe pour une femme je passe dans la
rue les gens me prennent pour une
nainette tous les gens dans votre cas
sont attirés par des femmes je que sais
qu'il y a beaucoup de travestis qui qui
aiment les femmes parce que je crois
comprendre qu'il y en a qui s'habill en
femme pour que des femmes on confond
travesti et puis homosexuel et dans le
fond ils se gourent les gens parce que
au lieu de dire r un travelot c'est un
[__] mais c'est fau ça na aucun rapport
Valérie vous pensez qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont envie de faire comme
vous mais qui n'osent pas aller jusqu'au
bout oh oui oh oui oui parce que je
connais des
péripathéticiennes bon et puis elles me
font des confidences puis ell me
racontent la moitié de leurs clients qui
viennent qui s'habillent en femme et
puis et puis qui font l'amour avec elle
en fin de compte et il y en a beaucoup
c'est comme ça et puis c'est des cadres
c'est des ingénieurs
c'est tu Gan bienen oui et puis ceux-là
sont eu les premiers à critiquer oh oh
un travesti patati et patatatin parce
que c'est la jalousie qui les font
parler en fin de compte c'est c'est ça
on critique pas parce que c'est mal mais
on critique parce qu'on est
[Musique]
jaloux on
continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Christian à qui sont toutes ces robes B
à moi toutes toutes oui
mis à part celles qui appartiennent au
spectacles quelles sont celles que vous
avez acheté pour votre plaisir
il m'en reste
j'en ai quelquesunes que je peux vous
montrer par exemple attendez j'en avais
vu une par ici il a celle-ci que
j'aimais
beaucoup une petite robe à
volant vous êtes sorti dehors avec elle
oui mais enfin dans des soirées pas dans
la rue parce que c'est pas une couleur
très discrète quand même et dans la rue
laquelle portez-vous où le plus
fréquemment euh dans la rue je euh j'en
ai j'en ai porté attendez je je ne sais
pas si je l'ai encore hein mais enfin
bien bon dans la rue c'est différent
c'était plutôt en style style Garson si
vous voulez c'était plutôt en style
unisexe vous avez des robes qui datent
de votre mariage des robes qui
appartenaient à votre femme
oui bah il y a il y a celle-ci m avait
fait cadeau céit femme oui jamais pu
parce qu'elle est démodée pourquoi la
gardez-vous comme
souvenir quand je fais mes courses dans
les magasins bon je regarde de temps en
temps les vêtements fémininsce qui vous
attire dans le vêtement féminin c'est
les robes les froufrous
tout je trouve ça magnifique ça peut
être considéré comme du fétichisme d'une
certaine façon mais aussi le côté
esthétique mais aujourd'hui pour acheter
vos chaussures à laasser pour acheter
vos dentelles vous allez tout seul dans
les magasins bien sûr oui on va pas
faire les courses pour moi je me
débrouille tout seul oui bien sûr vous
NZ pas honte oh plus maintenant non non
j'ai passé ce cap depuis longtemps avant
bon je me faisais accompagner par ma
femme
pour pour
avoir une contenance pour être moins
gêné et c'était elle qui qui choisissait
les accessoires pour moi dit bon
qu'est-ce que tu veux bah ça ça
m'intéresserait les acheter pour moi
alors quand il s'agissait des chaussures
bon faisait croire que c'était pour sa
sœur qui avait des des grands pieds on
allit chercher des scénarios pas
possible vous vous souvenez quand ça a
commencé la première fois oh ça fait il
y a très longtemps vous aviez quel
âge oh quand j'étais petit garçon quoi
dire un
âge je sais pas moi 7 8 ans j'avais une
é ucation bon c'estez rigide on ne
badinaait pas sur la moralité bon mes
parents étaient de très braves gens ils
m'ont appris bon à être poli à être
honnête à être courageux mais enfin sur
les choses de de la vie ils m'ont rien
appris comme beaucoup de d'enfants de ma
génération alors devant eux vous étiez
un petit garçon bien raisonnable comme
tous les petits garçons ah oui très très
raisonnable et derrière derrière bon un
garçon qui avait des problèmes et qui
les gardait pour lui quoi
il n'osait se confier à personne
pourquoi parce que c'est c'est des
choses qui à l'époque étai était plutôt
[Musique]
délicate pourquoi avez-vous accepté de
parler
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être parler
aujourd'hui parce que je pense qu'on
parle beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
peut-être de
travestis qui sont entachés de variantes
de de dévillan qui ne représent pas
notre cas qui êtes-vous exactement cadre
supérieur mariés des enfants vie
organisé dans cette situation là le
travestisme et quand même quelque chose
de troublant quelque chose qui dérange
aussi bien ma vie personnelle puisque
très longtemps cette situation m'a
angoissé il y a 15 ou 20 ans en arrière
on ne parlait pas de ce sujet c'était
quelque chose de de secret il y avait
très peu d'études médicales elles
étaient rconfidentielle la peste parlait
pratiquement pas les médias non plus on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que ça représente
1 2 ou 3 % de la
population Philippe vous êtes l'un des
membres de l'association pourquoi
avez-vous éprouvé le besoin de vous
regrouper quand on est travesti déjà
depuis de nombreuses années isolé non
pas dans le milieu familial mais au
moins dans le milieu social on est à la
recherche de gens qui ont le même
problème que
[Musique]
vous
nous essayons notre association de
réunir travestis
htérosexuel qui n' disons en terme
technique
aucunologie il y a
depos jus des personnages très
importants dans les hautes sphères
gouvernement
compris association est exactement comme
toute association qui tombe sur le coup
la loi 1901 qui a le président
vice-président trésorie
conseiladministration actuellement sur
la France nous avons environ 140 membres
par après quel est votre prénom
Josette quel est votre métier agent
technique depuis combien de temps
participez-vous à ces
réunions 2 ans alors tout à l'heure vous
avez quitté votre travail habillé en
homme comment s'est passé la fin de
votre journée et bien j'ai pris donc ma
voiture parking et puis je suis arrivé à
l'hôtel pourquoi l'hôtel à l'hôtel parce
que je me change toujours à l'hôtel pour
sortir pourquoi pas chez
vous pourquoi pas chez moi parce que il
y a
juste comment dire il y a justement des
personnes qui n'admettent pas ce genre
de chose et par certaines
caractéristiques je puis être
reconnu Lili je vais vous demander de
vous présenter qui
êtes-vous ma fois je suis un tout jeune
membre de
l'association mais ça fait très
longtemps
que que je
pratique comment diraisje que V
travestissez
travestisme et j'ai eu bien mérita ça
vous savez parce
que mon mon métier était maintenant je
suis en retraite n'est-ce pas mais mon
métier était marin et vous ne vous
imaginez pas les ruses qu'il faut
employer dans une société aussi fermé
hein quelques quelques dizaines de
personnes tous des mal hein
et des mal affirmés n'est-ce pas marin
c'est un métier d'homme comment
faisiez-vous alors bah justement c'était
là la difficulté à part prendre quelques
slips un peu vous voyez mifig mirisin je
ne pouvais guère faire autre chose hein
mais enfin si vous voulez la la
compensation était la suivante c'est que
revenu chez moi j'avais quelques mois de
libre devant moi et où là je pouvais
vraiment m'habiller en femme n'est-ce
pas de chez moi être femme d' d'illeurs
mais au retour du marin il y avait une
femme qui vous attendait
euh oui autre chis oui il y avait des
enfants des enfants qui sont au courant
aujourd'hui non mes enfants ne sont pas
au courant vous savez la vie est assez
compliqué comme ça ce n'est pas la peine
d'aller chercher des ennuis
supplémentaires enfin c'est mon point de
vue pourquoi avoir choisi puisque vous
connaissiez depuis longtemps vos
tendances pourquoi avoir choisi un
métier qui est un métier essentiellement
d'homme pourquoi avir chois
oui mais je ne regrette pas d'avoir
choisi ce métier j'ai aimé mon métier et
je vois pas pourquoi pour quelle raison
j'aurais abandonner un métier que
j'aimais c'est une des choses des
grandes choses de la vie de pouvoir
aimer ce qu'on fait son
métierri depuis combien de temps êt-vous
travesti depuis 10 ans et vous avez quel
âge 43 ans lorsqu'on est travesti et
qu'on habite un petit village est-ce que
les choses ne sont pas encore plus
difficiles pour moi elles ne sont pas
difficiles parce que on on m'accepte ou
on m'accepte pas moi je fais mon
travesti et puis c'est tout qu'est-ce
que vous faites dans la vie je suis
ingéneur mais vous avez tenu à ce que ça
se sache chez vous dans votre village
les gens sont curieux ils essayent de
ils viennent voir parfois ils essayent
de savoir et ils parviennent toujours à
le savoir enfin et ils l'ont su et ça
m'a pas pas du tout gêné
enfin qu ont été les réactions il y a eu
des réactions assez violentes parfois on
m'a déjà cassé un
carreau puis après ça s'est assé et ça
s'est calmé mais vous êtes resti depuis
10 ans pourquoi avez-vous attendu tout
ce
temps c'est bien simple je me suis
travesti parce que je ne trouvais plus
la femme qui correspondait à mes goûts
et
alors du fait que je n'avais pas de
femme qui euh
correspondait à mes goûts j'ai fait la
femme moi-même c'est du narcissisme
ça peut-être bien je n'en sais rien
enfin mais j'ai fait la femme moi-même
du fait que j'avais également un
physique une morphologie qui me
permettait de le faire notez bien que je
n'aurais
jamais continuer mon travestisme si je
m'étais aperçu que je ne pouvais pas
passer en société et c'est du fait que
je peux passer en société que j'ai
continué
Christian comment se sont passé les
premières années de vie commune du
mariage oh très bien on s'entendait très
bien c'était c'était parfait on était un
couple très très uni qui vivait en
harmonie et moi de mon côté bon j'étais
très sincère je voulait être un homme
normal et fondé un
foyer et puis euh on a vécu un certain
nombre d'années comme ça on a vécu à peu
près 10 ans ensemble ce qui est déjà pas
mal
et malgré tout il y a il y a cette
passion qui me qui ne me quittait pas
par le fait alors de temps en temps
j'essayé une de ces robes dire que ma
femme était assez grande de taille je
pouvais rentrer dans ses robes sans
qu'elle s'en aperçoit
[Musique]
pu un jour elle s'en est aperçu oui bien
sûr et c'est moi qui qui lui en ai parlé
et pourquoi votre femme n'a pas
accepté bien ma femme c'est une femme
normal qui aime les hommes les hommes
qui soient vraiment des hommes parce que
vous pas vraiment un
homme disons que je pense être un
personnage assez ambigu comme beaucoup
de personnages on a un côté masculin on
a un côté féminin avec une une dose plus
ou moins importante soit d'un côté soit
de
l'autre je pense être malgré tout être
un mélange les deux et cette ambiguité
pour rend malheureux euh m'a rendu
malheureux
oui parce que on est un peu assis entre
deux chaînes
lorsque vous avez compris qui il était
est-ce que ça a été un choc pour vous ça
a été un choc oui parce que l'homme
qu'on a épousé qui tout à coup est
transformé en femme n'est plus l'homme
qu'on a épousé
et bien sûr que ça ne change rien dans
son comportement mais pour moi ça change
tout parce que ce n'était plus lui-même
celui que j'avais connu en tout cas vous
pensez que vous lui avez rendu service
en le quittant oui oui très profondément
il il s'est épanoui il est sorti de
lui-même il est devenu lui-même et à
partir de là il n'a plus jouer ce ce
cinéma perpétuel d'essayer d'être autre
chose ou en tout cas de paraître autre
chose il a été lui-même et à partir de
là il a été profondément heureux il a
vécu sa vie normale il n'y avait plus de
retenue dans le fond à partir de ce
moment-là vous n'étiez plus tellement sa
femme vous étiez plus sa mère ah j'étais
plus sa mère j'étais sa confidente
j'étais sans card à certain moment il
s'est réfug vers quelqu'un qui était en
mesure de le comprendre parce que
personne ne comprend ces gens-là et
personne n'essaie de les
comprendre vous n'ignorez pas que j'ai
déjà été interviewé pour Antenne 2 et ce
qui s'est passé à cette époque-
là je travaillais en intérim dans une
entreprise dans un bureau
d'études et l'ambiance m'avait paru
assez
favorable pour que je puisse m'exprimer
vous comprenez d'autant que j'étais
assez survolté du du fait de ce tournage
j'attendais qui devait avoir lieu le
samedi en fin de
semaine alors je parlais mais le fait de
le dire simplement ça ça a suffit F le
lundi suivant le chef du bureau d'études
est arrivé il était en voyage
jusqu'alors et j'ai cru devoir lui
parler de cette affaire là et du
tournage qui avait lieu pour ane 2 il
n'a pas apprécié du tout il a décidé de
me
renvoyer mon premier mariage n'a pas
duré un an et demi juste second mariage
a été plus sérieux il a duré 23 ans
cependant la rupture était amorcée déjà
je pourrais dire 6 mois après le mariage
mon plaisir à m'habiller en femme un
moment atténué est
revenu de années consécutif j'ai fait
des crises morales où je croyais devenir
fou c'était
abominable vous avez eu ces dernières
années beaucoup de relations sexuelles
çaa fait 19 ans que je n'ai aucune
relation sexuelle
pourquoi perte de
désir ça vous chagrine ça m'a chagriné
ça m'a chagriné j'ai trouvé que c'était
complètement absurde complètement idiot
un vraisemblable on s'habitue même à
[Musique]
ça
et bien habillé en homme je ne peux pas
dire que je me sente aussi bien
qu'abiller en femme
c'est pas la même chose m sent moins à
l'aise en quelque sorte j'ai
l'impression d'être
travesti plus jamais vous ne sortirez
comme ça le moins possible si je su
encore à
travailler évidemment je serais obligé
de reprendre le costume
mascul sinon ce sera toujours le costume
féminintine la première fois que vous
êtes sorti hab en femme ça a été une
épreuve ah ça une épreuve
très il a fallu que je rassemble tout
mon courage pour déjà pour descendre mes
étages et ensuite pour franchir la
porte
la première fois que j'ai essayé c'était
relativement facile parce que j'ai
choisi de sortir à la nuit la première
fois vraiment difficile ça a été
d'aborder le plein jour et maintenant il
a fallu que je me fasse violence pour
sortir dans la rue et puis je me suis
aperçu que les gens n'avaient pas l'air
de prêter spécialement attention et
aujourd'hui quand on se retourne sur
votre passage qu'est-ce que vous pensez
je ne regarde pas si on se retourne sur
mon passage alors je ne sais pas
peut-être qu'il y en a qu' font les
autres vous sont
indifférents il faut vraiment planer
audessus vous ne souffrez plus à cause
des autres non je ne souffre plus à
cause des autres mais vous avez souffert
oui
certainement vous n'avez plus c'est vous
qui l'avez dit cet intense sentiment de
culpabilité
non non depuis que je me suis accepté je
n'ai plus de sentiment de
[Musique]
culpabilité
et vos parents Christi comment ontil
réagi pour l'instant ils nont pas ils
n'ont pas encore compris c'està-dire bon
ça le premier choc pour eux c'est
d'avoir appris que je me
séparé avec ma femme et puis un une un
second choc c'est
que après la séparation de ma femme j'ai
pas eu le courage
de de leur raconter tout c'està dire il
s'est passé une certaine période où je
n'ai pas donné une
nouvelle j'ai préféré attendre parce que
j'avais pris une décision très
grave j'avais
brutalement presque du jour la main
quitté mon métier bon j'étais métier qui
était
honorable et bon qui me permettait quand
même d'assurer mes arrières alors que là
je j'ai pris des risques qui ont été
calculés mais j'ai pris des risques
quand même c'est-à-dire du jour à Lain
j'ai tout plaqué pour venir travailler
dans un cabaret quand j'étais de faire
une demande d'audition dans un cabaret
où j'ai fait pour la première fois un
numéro là il s'est produit un choc
j'avais vraiment changé de de monde sur
le moment ça m'a fait un drôle d'effet
et j'ai eu des problèmes pour m'adapter
à ce nouveau milieu ce milieu de de la
nuit ce milieu de Gabaret qui est tout à
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
particulier
vous avez joué à pilfas et vous avez
l'impression d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui
gagné on dit jamais qu'on a gagné sur
toute la ligne a toujours bon on a
toujours des des succès des revers mais
disons bon ça s'est pas encore trop mal
passé ça aurait plus pu se terminer très
mal mon aventure alors pour l'instant je
me maintiens et je suis heureux comme je
suis
il de il y a trop d'enfant qui
pleur
dans le
temp
dans not ta
vie tu
trouveras la
vérité vous êtes heureuse de sa'avoir
bien dans sa peau parce qu'il est bien
dans sa peau il est parfaitement bien
dans sa peau ça c'est formidable moi je
suis bien un peu par ailleurs et je
comprends à quel point il a dû gâcher
gâcher j'insiste tant d'années de sa vie
à ne pas être ce qu'il aurait fallu
débloquer beaucoup plus
[Musique]
vite